voulez qu'on fasse entrer sa vie et avec
moi dix mots pour les voilà merci bungie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mon froc tu prennes ton tu prends
n'importe laquelle
c'est un château mais seront à l'affût
monde bon après une tonte tony brunetaud
tu vas jouer au ping pong avec 88,6
ménard passe à l'aller très calme vous
mettez en position de tous nos grands
gagnants tournant me rencontrera
toujours qu'un testicule à côté du rex à
l'époque ange amar ouais ben oui elle va
revenir on voit tranquille et me dérange
pas vraiment bien quoi oui à des
méchants que les gens lui télévisée non
mais oh ça va pas bien aller c'était
avant d'être envoyé aux quels il assez
rex attention mais c'est terminé pour
des très bons entre gouvernements
tiennent attendu avec les autres dans la
torture animale champion olympique ben
haim est divine est là
allez on y va il reste gilles isabelle
géraldine kadi jolie nom isabelle
éliminés ils sont plus que ces biens
n'ont pu rentrer bâtiment
chaud elle est méchante annulé je suis
dégoûté attention amis il reste deux
filles deux garçons qui va gagner
oui elvis est l'image et du cerf
géraldine tu sers attention on est
toutefois qu'aider géraldine ça joue
très bien
attention c'est la finale on enlève le
dit ce qui nous plaît alors entre vous
en un point et après je rencontre le
gagnant et juridictions qu'est-ce qu'il
a maintes fois autant à point
[Musique]
géraldine c'est très simple si vous me
battais way en deux points je vous le
dis oui je mettrai le slip de camping
pendant toute l'émission
d'accord on joue bas je choisirais
quelqu'un qui va pourtant le slip de
camping pendant toute l'émission
d'accord j'ai déjà une politique et s'en
priver les ans
pass 1 jour côtés d'armor la règle alors
est-ce qu'on fait deux points d'écart
badminton et l'autre comme bateau attend
5 ans sur balles de match j'ai gagné
tony you qui sony qui tu veux tu as ta
rennes a misé que huawei jeu les
visiteurs
je sais mais reçoit benjamin benjamin
castaldi
tu vas te préparer mon chéri curieux
dans un sens je voulais qu'on me fasse
rentrer
sa vie est avec moi dix mots pour les
voilà merci bonne grille
[Applaudissements]
on dirait vraiment maîtres nageurs sur
la mairie métier que ça te va y perdre
et bien sûr oui mais j'ai trouvé ton
style toi peut-être
[Musique]